good afternoon and welcome to at Yale
live I'm Eric Gershon in the months
ahead the US Supreme Court will consider
cases about same-sex marriage voting
rights affirmative action DNA testing
self incrimination and other questions
of consequence for American rights today
we'll discuss some of these disputes and
constitutional interpretation broadly
with one of the nation's foremost
constitutional scholars Akhil amar of
Yale Law School he is sterling professor
of law and political science at Yale and
the author of a series of books about
the Constitution most recently America's
unwritten Constitution viewers are
welcome to submit questions during
today's show through Yale's Facebook
page by tweeting at Yale or emailing us
at social media at yale.edu welcome
Akhil amar thanks for being with us
thank you big term for the Supreme Court
you've got a lot of huge issues which
are the ones that you are following most
closely and why well I think the Voting
Rights Act case the Shelby County case
which is going to be argued on February
27 so just about a week from now is
close to my heart and in fact I have a
piece about the case that's going to be
posted I hope but later this week if not
early next week on the Harvard Law
Review Online website on the case and
the reason that's close to my heart is
that justices have asked to basically
hear a challenge to one of the central
provisions of the Voting Rights Act of
1965 which has been reauthorized several
times since then a provision that
basically says that certain states with
really bad voting track records bad
histories of basically discrimination
and disfranchisement have to get federal
pre-approval before they institute new
changes in
vote in their voting procedures and it's
called section five of the Voting Rights
Act and and I think the section five is
easily and obviously constitutional
apparently there at least some justices
who have some doubts about this and the
reason that's I guess close to my heart
is because when I'm born in 1958 it is
not the case that voting rights are
really enforced on the ground in America
the Constitution promises voting rights
especially after the Civil War but as
late as the late 1950s and early 1960s
that wasn't the reality in places
basically the former Confederacy where
many blacks live most blacks were
actually unable to vote in the late 50s
and early 60s the world has profoundly
changed it's changed because of the
Voting Rights Act without that statute
you don't have President Barack Obama
you don't have the modern world so
that's for me an iconic statute it's not
an ordinary statute it's it's more like
itself a constitutional provision that's
a part of our unwritten Constitution
that law the Voting Rights Act and its
companion the the Civil Rights Act of
1964 is is washed in the blood of
American martyrs John Kennedy Abe
Lincoln Martin King John Lewis and Rosa
Parks and and so if that law were
actually struck down by the Supreme
Court would that would be a big deal and
a sad day so how do you see it playing
out well I think they're that they're
absolutely go to the bank on for solid
votes to uphold it no matter what those
are the that's the liberal wing of the
court justice Sotomayor Justice Kagan
Justice Breyer and so the
and of course Justice Ginsburg Ruth
Bader Ginsburg
so the opponents would have to fill an
inside straight they'd have to get every
one of the conservative justices and and
all my side has to do is peel off one of
them and I think we have different
arguments that might be appealing to
different members of the so-called
conservative wing so I put some stuff in
that I hope might be of interest even to
Justice Thomas who's raised some doubts
about this but is open to originalist
arguments and I made some originalist
Texas argument to Justice Scalia who
says that he's an originalist and is
open to these things to to Justice
Kennedy who has great admiration for the
civil rights movement and considers
himself a child I think of the a product
of the civil rights movement so so um
bad Chief Justice Roberts who I think
would care about the legacy of the
Roberts Court he's gonna use a very
young names gonna be on the court a long
time so there might be different
arguments that might and Justice Alito
is v I could imagine getting any one of
those I only need my sight only needs
one so but and in the Obamacare case for
example we the liberal for stuck
together and Chief Justice Roberts came
along in other cases it's been Justice
Kennedy who sometimes joined the
Liberals but but their very idea that
this is in play is kind of actually
unsettling to me I wouldn't have
predicted that five or ten years you
know I would have thought this is this
is a bedrock this is settled the voting
rights are are claimed by both parties I
would have thought and if you would run
through for us almost in list form I
have some of the other cases that you're
most energized about and most focused on
I think there's a very interesting case
also I think to be argued later this
month about DNA testing of people who
have been arrest and not convicted but
arrested and and their DNA is gotten
through like a cheek swab or something
and then put
in the database and analyzed there's a
case about whether the University of
Texas and an other public schools are
going to be allowed to engage in
race-conscious affirmative action in the
name of a diversity you remind me of
some of the others oh yeah well I you
know same-sex marriage oh of course that
both the the Defense of Marriage Act and
the California same-sex prop 8 Perry
case so too big actually same-sex
marriage cases one about a federal
statute and and whether the federal
statute actually has to recognize gay
marriage in states where it's legal
that's the the DOMA case the Defense of
Marriage Act case and then of course
there's another case out of California
very specific perhaps to the facts of
California California extended gay
marriage to gay couples and then later
took it away by a statewide initiative
and there's a question can you do that
once you've given it can you take it
back that way
how could I forget those um what else
what else interest know what I was gonna
ask you is of all these big cases which
one is going to be most important to an
individual is going to vary from person
to person based on court particular
their personal interest yes but I guess
I would ask you which of these cases
seems most likely depending on the
outcome to cause sudden and widespread
change in American society well if the
Voting Rights Act were eliminated or
this key portion of it an act that I
think has really served America very
well an act that passed with
overwhelming congressional majorities
when it came up for renewal I don't have
the numbers in front of me but vast
majorities of both parties supporting it
signed into law by and and reauthorized
and reauthorized by a series of
presidents of both parties well then
we'd need maybe to provide some
substitute for the law that was struck
down the parties are having difficulty
agreeing about a lot of stuff so to
invalidate the Voting Rights Act would
be a very big deal so whereas in gay
marriage my own sense from a kind of a
philosophical or political science
perspective is no matter what the
Supreme Court does this term we're gonna
have gay marriage nationwide and ten
years no matter what the court does this
term because even if they said no gay
marriage right even in California now
California's are free to adopt gay
marriage and will do so soon enough
within the next couple of years I think
just when you look at the polling data
and and the demographic trends every
year people who believe in equality and
gay marriage come of age and those that
are skeptical of gay marriage in general
are dying quicker so so you do the math
people who are skeptical of gay marriage
or older Americans are leaving this
world and and those who are very Pro gay
marriage are becoming voters so no
matter what the Supreme Court does we're
gonna have gay marriage and a whole
bunch of states soon and then once it's
in a majority of states the Supreme
Court will come along and nationalize it
even if they're not ready to do so and
that will be a necessary step in order
for gay couples to enjoy all the same
rights under federal law of course that
that heterosexual couples are entitled
to right welcomed and under federal law
that's the DOMA case the Defense of
Marriage Act case and and that even if
that one happened quickly a court could
split the difference I could imagine a
court saying the federal government has
to recognize same-sex marriages in
states where same-sex marriage is legal
okay so that would that would um but
states are free to choose I could
imagine that I'm not supporting that but
but if that were to happen what I'm
saying is states are increasingly going
to
choose same-sex marriage and then the
federal government will recognize those
and eventually the court might for
example say oh the federal government
isn't the only government has to
recognize same-sex marriage if two
people from Connecticut where it's legal
go to Utah and get married I'm sorry two
people from Utah where it's not legal
come to Connecticut get married and then
go back Utah has to recognize that
marriage well once you've done that once
you've said even states that don't have
same-sex marriage have to recognize
other states same-sex marriage you've
basically come this close to
nationalizing the thing in the same way
that way back when everyone you know
want to get a quick divorce would go to
Nevada Sand Nevada basically drove the
divorce laws for the country every if if
Connecticut or Massachusetts or these
other states that that saw my same-sex
marriage if their marriages have to be
recognized in the other places well then
all you need to people need is you know
just to be in love with each other and
and a train ticket or a plane ticket
they go get married so so I think
same-sex marriage is here to stay and
will be nationalized the only question
is how quickly whereas if the Voting
Rights Act were invalidated I don't know
if today's Republican Party would
support a reauthorization of the sort
that we I'd like to see hmm let me
introduce a topic that I don't believe
is before the Supreme Court now and I
don't know when it will be but given
given how prevalent the issue is and at
the forefront of our minds now seems
like it will be at some point before too
long and that's gun control so do you
envision a gun control case in the near
future and what might trigger it
lots of gun control cases and here's why
because for most of American history the
Supreme Court said next to nothing about
the Second Amendment there was a case
from 1939 called Miller it was read in
different ways
but but then in 2008 a case called
heller came along in in Heller the
Supreme Court announced really for the
first time clearly the Second Amendment
protects an individual right to have a
gun in the home for self-protection and
maybe beyond that but the core right
that an individual has is a gun in the
home for self-protection Heller
invalidated a DC ordinance Washington DC
that in effect was a blanket prohibition
on guns in homes okay
then two years later later a case called
city of Chicago versus McDonald said
that right which the Second Amendment
affirms against federal law and the
federal government and therefore DC
which is governed by federal law that
right a Second Amendment right right to
an individual to have again in the home
for self-protection also applies against
states and localities and in particular
Chicago which also had this draconian
ban on guns even in homes that law
couldn't stand now there are lots of gun
measures that are less draconian than
Chicago's and DC's and there's very
little Supreme Court pronouncement just
those two cases 2008 2010 so we're going
to get lots of litigation by challenging
various state laws various local
ordinances and if Congress gets around
to doing something I don't know whether
they will possibly a federal law I think
most of the laws that are actually on
the table right now could pass that are
politically realistic the proposals that
we've been hearing about could pass
muster in the courts um some of the
proposals for example would be universal
background checks limits on the size of
the gun clip the magazine how many
bullets you that you can have in a in a
in a magazine limits on the amount of
ammo you can buy at any one time their
number of guns you could stockpile
all sorts of restrictions that wouldn't
really interfere with the core right of
an individual to have a gun and
home for self-protection mental health
checks particularly strong penalties for
straw purchasers people who actually buy
guns on behalf of others who wouldn't be
eligible to buy them themselves those
are the things that are frankly
politically realistic and so some of the
constraints as a practical matter are
political constraints that are probably
if anything as high as the
constitutional judicial constraints
would be um the one thing that might
have be in trouble in the court is a ban
on assault weapons if the ban were seen
as kind of cosmetic actually not really
distinguishing between different weapons
on the basis of their real hardware and
firepower and lethality and their their
their actual capacity but for example
because one gun looks nastier it's got a
bayonet it's got a flash something or
other it's it's got a plastic stock
rather than a wooden stock and and then
the court might say we think that these
comes medical laws are motivated by kind
of an impermissible purpose and anti-gun
purpose precisely because they really
don't deal with real problems
we're doubtful about this so so I say
avoid cosmetic laws pass real gun
control measures that nevertheless
respect the core right of an individual
have a gun self-protection
and maybe because of Heller and McDonald
are ironically maybe gun control is a
little easier to do politically because
people can't say this is the first step
on the slope slippery slope that will
lead to confiscation because judge
Scalia won't let that happen we have two
Supreme Court cases now that say you
can't do that and so maybe we can have
reasonable gun control and people also
have a right to have guns and homes in
just a minute we're gonna take some
questions from the public but before we
get there I want to ask you a sort of a
process question would you explain for
our viewers how it is that cases get
before the Supreme Court that is how the
court decides what cases to hear in what
case is that it's simply gonna let rest
it has vast discretion in any given year
there are thousands for five thousand
applications for the Supreme Court to
review a case in the recent past the
Supreme Court has heard anywhere from
eighty to a hundred cases a year so you
do the math it's very unusual what
factors predict that a Supreme Court
will take a case two or three one if the
lower courts are divided on an issue if
the circuits are split that will at a
certain point typically prompt the
supreme court to get involved to clarify
and harmonize the law to come up with a
uniform rule for for the various lower
courts second and related if the United
States government the Solicitor General
asks that a case be heard by the Supreme
Court the odds increased dramatically
that the Court will hear such a case
okay and do the dress this is actually
vote in their private chamber they do
and the basic rule it's a minority rule
four justices are enough to basically
hear the case interesting so it's the
rule of four now once they've heard the
case five justices because could say you
know we've heard it but we actually now
decided that we think we just shouldn't
we want to dismiss it and so we we quote
dig the case we dismiss it as
improvidently granted so the oral
arguments before that typically I mean
the five could do anything they want
because majority rules and we can talk
about the filibuster and and I'm
actually majority ruled as a deep
constitutional principle but the
tradition is four justices are enough to
basically put the case on the agenda and
by tradition putting the case on the
agenda would mean at least having
briefing and argument but after that
it's possible to imagine the five
justices saying well it was briefed
we heard the oral argument we actually
think that we don't want to get involved
okay we're gonna take a couple questions
that we have on coming in via Twitter
from at WD Portman and he asks a couple
of questions that I'll let you decide
which of these you're most interested in
in answering but he's curious to know if
you have any thoughts on mandatory
minimums and whether juries or judges
should decide when they apply and also
interested in what the major differences
are between this year's affirmative
action case
and the big one from 2003 Gregory
Bollinger excellent so actually this new
book America's unwritten Constitution
has a chapter on our savage criminal
punishment system with particular
emphasis on three strikes laws where a
person might go to prison for the rest
of his life for stealing a slice of
pizza or a baseball glove if that's his
third offense and mandatory minimum laws
which can be extremely harsh and the
chapter is about what should a
conscientious judge or juror do if the
punishment really is unconscionable so
this is a chapter about what a critic
might call jury nullification the
ability of a jury or judge to just say
no in the name of mercy and toward that
a criminal defendant so the the rule is
that if a jury acquits even if the
person is pretty plainly guilty to the
judge the person walks the and I argued
that jurors um we should have morally
serious instruction so jurors are told
these are the rules they're told what
the sentencing consequences might be
and they're also told about the history
of improper jury nullification in
American history where Klansmen walked
free
because all-white juries in the South
acquitted them when these Klansmen had
lynched and murdered a black people is
that an argument for some kind of
mandatory minimums that is depending on
its well I my argument is that jurors
should know what the sentencing
consequences are so they shouldn't be
told simply ladies and gentlemen the
jury the question before you simply did
the persons I'm still the slice of pizza
and here's the videotape they should be
told ladies and gentlemen the jury the
question is did the person steal the
slice of pizza and if you say yes this
person goes to prison for the rest of
their lives or if you say yes to this
that the person had this amount of drugs
there's a mandatory minimum they
jurors should be told what they are
really actually doing when they come
back with a guilty verdict Blackstone
referred to a certain practice of
English juries as pious perjury perjury
is wrong it's a false swearing but he
thought it was pious what did he mean by
pious perjury situations where juries
came in with verdicts that were actually
more merciful than the facts warranted
in specifically if you stole something
and it was worth more than a pound let's
say it's a horse that's grand larceny
and you must hang by the neck a capital
offense but if the horse was worth less
than a pound petty larceny and then you
just be sent off to Georgia or Australia
now everyone knows and the questions
strictly speaking is it 100 people saw
you steal the horse that's not a
question the only question is whether it
was grand or petty larceny was the horse
worth more than the pound now everyone
in the jury knows that the horse is
worth more than a pound but sometimes
they'd come back with a verdict of petty
larceny saying the horse was not very
valuable in order to be merciful to the
defendant to spare his life and send him
instead to Georgia and Blackstone this
is a very long tradition this referred
to this as pious perjure yes it was
perjury in a way they acquitted of grand
larceny but it was motivated by certain
piety a certain sense of conscience and
and mercy and so are you saying that
there's no way for jurors in our system
to do that because they don't
necessarily know exactly what sometimes
judges tell them if the the horse was
worth more than a pound if the cocaine
weighed more than a certain immigrant
you must convict and a lot of times
they're not told what the sentencing
consequences of that would be that this
is a mandatory minimum case I think they
should be told but the sentencing
consequences should be I think they
should be told that in fact they do have
the power to acquit against the evidence
and they should be told that that power
has been abused in American history and
and and so we need they need to actually
have a serious conversation about
whether this is appropriate
for in effect when a critic would call
jury nullification but there's a great
American tradition of jury nullification
and judges basically saying I judges as
a matter of conscience for example
saying I refuse to sign my name on a
death warrant I will oppose every
capital sentence Thurgood Marshall at
the end of his career said that he would
oppose every single capital sentence
death sentence
so did William Brennan so did Harry
Blackmun at the very very end of his
time on the court John Stephens at the
end said something a little less
absolutist but I think there might be a
role and it's it's it's complicated and
and I want the reader to wrestle with
this as I want jurors and judges to
wrestle with the moral complexity of
sending vulnerable human beings who are
standing before you in the courtroom and
subjecting them to savage punishment
they may have done terrible things but I
want the judges and the jurors to really
wrestle with what is a morally sensible
punishment any thoughts on the oh those
affirmative action case yes and and that
sort of fundamental differences between
the current case and the O 3 Bollinger
case two differences one justice
O'Connor used to be the swing justice
she no longer is she was replaced by
Justice Alito who's more hostile to
affirmative action that means a new
swing justice is not Sandra Day O'Connor
but Tony Kennedy who is more skeptical
of affirmative action
that's just em and and so that's the
legal realist difference O'Connor isn't
the swing Justice Kennedy is because
O'Connor was replaced by Alito who's to
her right so to speak on affirmative
action the factual difference is that in
the the University of Texas arguably had
a more did more affirmative action in a
sort of a heavier handed way with less
sort of finesse then
the Gruder case demands Gruder says you
can do affirmative action but these
things must be done delicately you know
very very sensitively without too much
weight on race as opposed to other
factors and only as part of one holistic
process and the argument is that's not
what Texas did let's take another
question this one is about gun control
again and this one comes from a
gentleman named Martin Coburn who who
described himself as a Yale alumnus he
says in my ongoing discussions with my
pro-gun friends they claimed echoing
Wayne LaPierre that one of the purposes
of the Second Amendment was to allow
citizens to resist tyrannical government
my contention is that if this had been
the aim of the founders and they would
have simultaneously repealed article 3
section 3 of the Constitution which
defines treason as quote levying war
against the United States
one man's resistance is another's
treason how do you respond to that that
and if you would just tell our viewers
exactly what our article three section
three is article three section three
ordinate mainly is about the role of
judges but it has some special rules
defining treason against the United
States which consists of levying war
against the United States and giving aid
and comfort to their enemies and
prescribing special rules that you have
to actually have two witnesses
testifying to the same overt act so it's
in article 3 because it's partly about
what you have to prove in court if
you're going to call someone a traitor
an article 3 is generally about the
rules governing the judiciary article 1
is the legislature article 2 is the
executive article 3 is the judiciary now
for since this is from a Yale alum I
would encourage everyone to go see the
Trumbull gallery and at the heart of
Yale University art gallery there's a
beautiful painting by John Trumbull on
the Battle of Bunker Hill which does
capture a certain founding vision it's
local militias against the imperial
Redcoats in resisting tyranny by local
militias a couple of things though about
that
vision 1 no one voted for Parliament so
local militia resistance in Lexington
Concord Bunker Hill was against an
unrepresentative government ok and that
was and no one voted for the king of
England who was a tyrant and that's what
the Declaration of Independence all
about all the tyrannical things that he
and Parliament did and there wasn't a
way to vote the bums out mm-hmm but in
America's Constitution we have elections
and so if you think your government we
have courts and we have free speech so
if you think your government has done
something wrong you have to go to court
well you have to you know and and prove
that they've done something wrong where
you have to actually persuade your
fellow citizens with free speech and and
elections ballots not bullets and this
lesson was lost on the antebellum South
they took up arms claiming that they
were doing just like 1776 but they
weren't this is beginning the antebellum
South took up arms against a duly
elected government and they could claim
that Lincoln was a time he hadn't done
anything they had they'd actually
seceded a bunch of them before he'd even
taken the oath of office they can say
all sorts of things but taking up arms
against a duly elected government it's a
very different thing than taking up arms
in in 1776 or 1775 against a tyrannical
King George another way of saying that
is our second our Constitution is a
reflection of our history our history is
defined largely by our Wars and yes the
Second Amendment has a little bit of
this revolutionary echo state militias
against an imperial center but the
Second Amendment isn't the only
amendment on this topic the Fourteenth
Amendment is relevant as well that was
adopted after the Civil War remember I
told you there were two gun cases there
was the Heller case about DC and then
the city of Chicago versus McDonald's
case that says the same Second Amendment
rights apply against States and locality
why because in the Revolutionary War the
states are the heroes the imperial
government they're the bad guys and and
we have local juries and local militias
and local assemblies organizing against
the imperial center that's the
Revolutionary War but after the Civil
War it became clear that states could
misbehave and had misbehaved and they
had actually shut down free speech and
shut down Free Press they made a crime
to criticize slavery it was a federal I
mean assuming a capital offense in North
Carolina to criticize slavery to be an
effective member of the Republican Party
they took up arms against a duly elected
government they shut down preachers in
the pulpit who preached against slavery
so the 14th mm which is a reflection of
the Civil War
not just the Revolutionary War I says
states need to be reined in no state can
can mess with fundamental rights and in
the process redefined fundamental rights
yes for the framers it was about local
militias against its tyrannical army but
after the Civil War we don't love those
state militias anymore they fought
against the army and the army that's our
army that's us grant that's Abe Lincoln
that's Tom Hanks in Saving Private Ryan
we today do not think that the federal
government and the Federal Army or some
aliens Hessians mercenaries Imperial
jackbooted thugs we think they are us we
elect them they so so after the Civil
War the vision of arms bearing in
America was applied against the states
and rican Sep shoe alized refined the
new vision the which is the Civil War
vision is not taking up arms against a
tyrannical government but guns in homes
for self-protection why because after
the Civil War blacks in their homes
couldn't count on local cops to protect
them when the Klan came calling and so
they would need guns in their homes for
self-protection the National Rifle
Association Wayne LaPierre Association
was founded after the Civil War by a
group of X Union Army officers and they
were actually opposed the Klan that
tried to take guns away from black
people in their homes so the founding
vision
was this malicious against a tyrannical
central government but two things
happened one we created a constitution
when the central government actually be
representative you know democratic and
and with all sorts of other checks the
First Amendment free speech elections
lawsuits so I don't know about this
tyranny thing you know if you lose an
election fair and square you got a you
know win on your second after we amended
the Constitution after the civil war to
reflect a different vision of Liberty in
America one not nearly so protective of
states rights and rather much more
focused on individual rights to have
guns in the home for self-protection so
in one sentence founding vision when the
guns are out when guns are out log only
the king's men will have guns
reconstruction vision when guns are
outlawed only Klansmen will have guns
which is like when guns are outlawed
only Outlands that's the modern vision
and and so this these people who oh talk
about resisting federal tyranny miss the
fact that the federal government was
duly elected so in your view does the
Second Amendment and title Americans to
have any weapon and all weapons that
they can get ahold of no so so so so
clearly regulation is is is authorized
and it's really almost purely a question
of politics well it's a question of
politics because as a practical matter
the political skepticism of gun control
ensures that anything that actually
passes is going to be pretty moderate
and reasonable so um let's actually do
the Constitution us there's the Second
Amendment I told you what that was about
there's the Fourteenth Amendment I told
you what that was about the ninth
amendment says there unenumerated rights
even if we didn't have a second
Amendment right to have a gun in a home
maybe we should have it we have an
unenumerated right the same way where
does it say in the Constitution you have
a right to privacy or to play the fiddle
or to have a pet dog or to raise your
children those are all unenumerated
rights so is a right to have a
in your home is part of the American
tradition and culture and this is a lot
of what you get into in your book there
unenumerated rights and and that a game
that conservatives cultural
conservatives can play as well as
liberals if if gay Americans have a
right to have sex in their homes free
from criminalization and Justice Kennedy
joined the Liberals in the case called
Lawrence saying that you know why not
guns and homes as well as sex in homes
you know the Liberals like the sex and
the conservatives like guns and I say
give them both what they want this is
America I personally you know prefer sex
but that's maybe just me so even without
the Second Amendment there's a big
American culture and tradition that
respects guns and homes they're almost
as many guns and homes as there are
Americans almost 300 million guns by
many counts even if you wanted to get
rid of them
you couldn't as a practical matter you
know prying them loose from you know um
every American where where the art would
make prohibition look like a walk in the
park it would be a a Fourth Amendment
search and seizure nightmare a civil
libertarian nightmare even if you want
to do all that oh and most states have
state constitutions that have
counterpart language about guns so so so
so what I say is there's a right to have
a gun the core of the right is a gun in
the home for self-protection there's all
sorts of regulation reasonable
regulation that would be consistent with
that and and maybe the next big case is
going to be about people who carry guns
outside the home in concealed ways and
whether laws state laws that restrict
the concealed carrying of a weapon
violate the core right so I say there's
a core right but it's subject to a
reasonable regulation that doesn't
infringe upon that core right which is
guns and homes for self-protection
you mentioned privacy and we have
question coming in from Facebook from
Mattie al husseiny and he says in our
increasingly globalized and tech
oriented world the right of privacy
seems to be a gradually diminishing
principle of freedom with policies such
as the Patriot Act
established under the banner of domestic
security such policies permit
wiretapping heavy surveillance of
particular individuals among other
things what with that in mind what is
the feature of our privacy rights in
your mind is this the beginning of an
era where Big Brother is always watching
or is it sort of a passing trend well
boy there are a lot of provisions of the
Patriot Act and they're scattered
throughout us code and I don't know what
particular provisions he's identity is
worried about and I might agree with him
on some visions and disagree with him on
others and I'm not sure I would say yeah
we have less privacy net-net than our
forebears did we have new technologies
of surveillance but in the lorentz case
for example in the in the 21st century
the Supreme Court said government cannot
make it a crime for people even of the
same sex to have sexual relations now
the founding there were laws on the
books prohibiting same-sex conduct and
throughout the 19th century there were
laws on the books and the 20th century
too now the Lawrence Court said yes but
those laws weren't very vigorously
enforced between consensual adults in
private but still only in this century
did the court say those laws are
unconstitutional only in this century
did courts proclaim in cases like
Griswold versus Connecticut and
Eisenstaedt versus bear a robust right
of privacy saying government can't
prohibit the sale of contraception
government has to allow people to use
contraception and in the home and buy
contraception so I think in in in
various ways course have been sensitive
to American privacy interest courts have
said you can homeschool your kids you
can have a gun in your private dwelling
place for self-protection you have a
certain sexual intimacy in your
home you actually have a right to erotic
material in your home okay so it's in
some ways it's it's become liberalized
that's my view compared to the founding
era where on the books at least there
are all sorts of quite sexually
intolerant repressive anti privacy rules
that were in place so so I'm not sure
it's the case that I not sure I agree
with the premise that we've really you
know lost all our privacy rights from
Facebook
Edmund balilla asks raises the Defense
of Marriage Act again and I don't know
if you have any sort of final thoughts
on on that on how you think it's likely
to play out this time well on that one
some conservatives who believe in states
rights might ally with liberals who
believe in individual rights of sexual
liberty and equality and so you might
get a coalition possibly in which the
the idea is the Defense of Marriage Act
DOMA is wrong because the federal
government should respect state marriage
laws because ordinarily it does for
example usually you know state law
decides whether two people are married
that's that's part of family law and and
and in most states first cousins can get
married for example but not in all
states
I do mean most days first cousins can't
get married but in some states they can
and and the federal government basically
respects state law on that matter now
the rule the age of consent might
marriage consent marital consent might
vary a little bit from state to state
and ordinarily the federal government
just follows state rules on that so I
could imagine the Supreme Court saying
the federal government should treat you
as married if your state treats you as
marry that's you know this is just a
part of American federalism I could
imagine me me one justice saying that a
conservative justice maybe Justice
Kennedy saying that joined
I the Liberals who believe basically
that you should have same-sex marriage
should be the law everywhere so liberals
who believe in same-sex marriage as a
general proposition need basically one
or you know conservative who believes in
states rights and wants to rein in the
federal government and then you'd have
five votes to strike down the Defense of
Marriage Act question tweeted at us by
at Yale women which is the global
network of Yale women alumni they're
interested know if you have any thoughts
on what the recent lift on the the
banner of women in combat by the
military whether that's likely to affect
women's rights more broadly at on the
national scale yes it is I have a whole
chapter in this but maybe my favorite
chapter called remembering the ladies
that's a quote from gonna show the book
Emily Abigail Adams America's feminist
Constitution so here's one thing that's
it's unwritten in our Constitution
how broadly should we read amendments to
change what happened before earlier I
said the 14th amendment changed the
meaning of gun rights in America
originally it was about state militias
against a federal army and now it's
actually a right against States as well
as the federal government and it's an
individual right for self-protection
rather than you know an anti tyranny
idea okay
so I say the 14th amendment changed the
Second Amendment in some really
important ways let's take the First
Amendment says Congress shall make no
law abridging free speech but today we
think states can't make laws abridging
free speech a free press or religion now
let's take the 19th amendment that's the
woman suffrage amendment I think this is
a radical amendment because actually it
doubles the franchise it's you know it's
a really big epic idea article 2 says
what about the president he/him/his but
I think Hillary Clinton has a right to
be present I think Sarah Palin has a
right to be vice president no state
could keep them off the ballot but where
does it say that in the Constitution it
says he him his I say the 19th amendment
has a profound gravitational pull on not
just who can vote but who can be voted
for
can be eligible to be present I think
actually womens military rights and
responsibilities are and connected up
with their political right to
responsibility political and military
rights have always gone hand in hand at
the founding unpretty supported the
American Revolution they were there at
Lexington and Concord Bunker Hill they
got to vote at the Civil War blacks
fought black men Denzel Washington you
know and in the movie glory black men
fought on the battlefield and they got
the vote in the 15th amendment in World
War two women are sort of part of a
struggle against Germany and they get
the vote Woodrow Wilson supports women's
suffrage the 19th amendment as a war
measure in my lifetime 18 year-olds
fighting and dying in Vietnam and so the
Constitution gets amended as a they have
a right to vote on whether it should be
in Vietnam so military rights and
responsibilities have always been linked
up in some ways with political rights
and responsibilities interests and we
are more likely to see women presidents
and women senators when we have women
warriors I two weeks ago was in DC
giving a talk to House Democrats I
didn't get a chance to to pay my
respects to her to see her but Tammy
Duckworth was there and she lost her
legs actually in combat and she's a
genuine war hero in the same way that
John McCain is a genuine war hero and
John Kennedy and John Kerry and Bob
Kerry and Bob Dole and in an earlier
world it was the John's and Bob's who
were the war heroes and came back you
know and became senators and presidents
you know the Kennedys and the Kerry's
and and the doles and McCain's and it
wasn't the Joanna's and Roberta's it was
the you know the Roberts and the John's
but but as women so this is a deep
unwritten entailment of the 19th
amendment if women are voting they
should be sort of have the right
responsibility to serve equally
which will feed back into our system and
make them more credentialed to be
secretaries of state secretaries of
defense presidents the United States
senator nighted states so these things
fit together in an unwritten way I want
to squeeze in one more question before
we close one is from a yale law student
whom you may or may not know named aaron
gold Zimmer and I'm gonna paraphrase his
his question I think he'd like you to
address whether you think and this is a
broad question but is American
constitutional democracy functioning
well or not do you do you agree with the
premise that it may not be compared to
what so we are in I'm not great shape
right now in some respects compared to
where we were as a country let's say 30
40 years ago but are we worse off than
England or France or Italy or India or
other great democracies in Chapter 1 of
my last book I tried to explain what the
source of America's strength you're
referring to America's unwritten
Constitution that that was the pre which
was a sequel to a book called America's
Constitution of biography and when I
tried to show an America's Constitution
of biography is that a lot of what made
America free was our oceans we basically
four first hundred fifty years didn't
have a standing army in peacetime so
we'd have to pay for it and that didn't
threaten our Liberty meanwhile the rest
of the world
you know tyrants and who oppressed them
and we have these massive oceans that
protect us from these tyrannies and we
don't need an army
and so now what's happened in the last
50 years the rest of the world has
actually become increasing American
they've adopted democracies they've
gotten rid of these military
dictatorships easter-egg ich regimes and
places like Japan and Germany and Italy
and elsewhere they're becoming American
so we're kind of more competing with
ourselves and and so there's gonna be an
evening of America is the only nation on
its feet after World War two everyone
else is on their knees or on their backs
20 million Russians die bombs have
rained over a parliament and France has
been occupied so so compared to 1950 or
1960 yes there's been
a certain evening app because we have a
huge military complex that we are
financing now that we didn't use to the
rest of the world isn't paying for for a
big military they've become democratic
on the American this is good for the
world I'm good for you yeah looks a lot
different now than it used to people
from around the world so that's a
certain evening up we're no longer you
know as far ahead as everyone else we're
also in the middle of a political
transition the Republicans have been in
the ascendancy really since Reagan and
now Democrats are actually maybe so in
this time of transition the parties are
deeply divided and polarized and but I
don't see our system as fundamentally
more flawed we you know we had an
economic downturn
so did Europe so did England so I don't
see us as worse off than they are they
have a parliamentary system they have
multiple party systems that works well
for them I don't think that you know
that we should impose our system on them
but our system has worked well for us
they drive on you know the left side of
the road we drive on the right side the
world we've both made it work and here's
why I say you know our basic
constitutional system isn't deeply
flawed and this is the last chapter of
the book when I imagine what
constitutional amendments we should
adopt here's my reason for being
somewhat complacent we have 50 state
constitutions and they look a lot like
the Federal Constitution and they're
easy to amend and they haven't been
amended so they have written
constitutions and a bill of rights and
judicial review and juries and bicameral
legislatures except in Nebraska and
governors who look a lot like presidents
and a jury system and to parties um so
that's the American system and in any
state that wants to change it can but
the states haven't done it so I think
it's worked pretty well for us and and
other societies they've got good
constitutions that you know are working
well for them so we have our problems
but on balance I'm I'm I'm not you know
moving to Canada okay we've got just
about a minute or two left and I want to
ask you to two closing questions and
I'll just ask them together one
are you gonna be an attending oral
arguments for any of the cases coming up
at the Supreme Court and this is
somewhat of non sequitur but do you have
another book project already in the
works thanks for asking so I think DC is
sufficiently far away from New Haven and
I important thing is I got to teach my
classes and and and so so I will be
watching these things from afar through
the magic of of transcripts and radio
and if they I would love it if they
actually televised but that's not
happening in the in the near term but
but I can listen to radio transcripts
are often audio transcripts and and and
so that's how I'll be following goings
on in the Supreme Court I will be
appearing
I think this Sunday on the Melissa
harris-perry show MHP on MSNBC from
10:00 to noon to talk about the Voting
Rights case where I have written a piece
this forth it's going to be online later
this week in the Harvard Law Review so I
care a lot about that voting rights
issue and the next book I think I'm just
about to start I like to write books
about the entirety of the American
Constitution experience America's
Constitution of biography took the
reader through the written text from
start to finish from the preamble
articles 1 2 3 etc and then all the
amendments this book says well there's
more than just the written constitution
there's an unwritten Constitution here
are different ways of thinking about an
unwritten Constitution that doesn't lose
touch with the text the next book I
think is going to be chronological it's
going to be called maybe at 12 score
America's constitutional conversation
1760 to 2000 and I'm gonna have 12
chapters each a score 20-year period
talking about the great American
conversation that we've held amongst
ourselves I'm among citizens in that
conquer Congress and the courts in the
executive branch for 240 years we've
been debating constitutional issues
sometimes disagreeing with each other
sometimes pretty fiercely but always in
the end you know part of a of a
constitutional conversation that has
endured well we'll look forward to that
and I want
thank you very much for joining us today
and I want to thank all of you for
watching at Yale live we'll look forward
to having you join us again next month
thanks so much